klingerman has an art installation has
several art installations actually that
uses that algorithm to generate
infinitely many portraits so as you come
into this room these paintings of people
just get generated forever and ever and
you can look at them the thing about
this installation is that it wasn't
possible five years ago it wouldn't have
been possible without these machine
learning algorithms that we have today a
painter is not able to generate
infinitely many
portraits we can count to Infinity it's
like a lot it takes a bunch of time so
this is a way that we can use machine
learning in art and still maintain that
Integrity of Art